Transcriptor: Federica Bruno
Revisor: Almudena Torrecilla
Cuando era pequeña, una de mis películas
favoritas era Mary Poppins.
Siempre ha sido Mary Poppins.
¿Saben por qué?
Porque tiene esta bolsa que viene
preparada para absolutamente todo.
La bolsa tiene lo que puede necesitar.
Y porque se puede sentir preparada
en cualquier momento
para cualquier cosa que necesite,
sin importar lo que sea.
El momento es lo que lo dicta
y a ella nunca le falta nada.
Entonces, me gustaba la idea
de estar preparada para todo.
Y hubo un momento donde yo sentía
que ya no tenía el control de las cosas.
Y ese fue el momento en el que
estaba a punto de graduarme
de mi carrera de licenciatura.
Y ¿qué licenciatura tengo?
Pues licenciatura
en la carrera más inútil.
En la carrera que toda la gente
cuando llega su hijo o su hija
y le dice: “Ah, sí, quiero estudiar”.
Yo soy licenciada en Literatura.
Es cierto.
Y mucha gente, cuando yo dije
que ese quería que fuera mi futuro,
me hizo bullying, se burló de mí,
me dijo que no iba a encontrar un futuro
y me hizo sentir totalmente desprotegida,
insegura y poco preparada.
Y es que, para empezar,
¿qué es literatura?
Esta es la definición que da la RAE.
Bueno, son ocho definiciones
las que da la RAE,
incluyendo una que dice “palabrería”.
Está bien.
La verdadera pregunta es:
¿Para qué sirve un literato?
Es lo que están pensando todos Uds. ahora:
Bueno, si vamos a la definición
estaría el lado técnico:
Es la persona que conserva,
preserva y divulga
conocimiento, arte y entretenimiento.
Si vamos a la definición
de lo que realmente hacíamos
mis compañeros de carrera y yo:
es la persona que despilfarra
un salario insostenible en fotocopias,
libros usados y alicientes
para la depresión.
Entonces estaba yo a punto
de pasar a mi tercer año
en la carrera donde
me he sentido más enamorada,
porque yo he sido más feliz
cuando estaba con los libros.
Con los libros más gruesos, con los libros
más viejos, con los más desgastados,
porque yo soñaba con ser un escritor,
con impactar con esas historias
que nos llevan a imaginar lugares lejanos
e imaginar un futuro.
Y con esas historias gruesas
que no se toma un minuto leerlas.
Yo quería pasarme horas.
Era feliz pasando horas en la biblioteca,
escribiendo y leyendo.
Y ¿por qué no me merecía
un futuro con eso?
¿Por qué me merecía todas las burlas
y no me merecía un futuro?
Yo veía a mis compañeros
terminando en carreras peores,
terminando en carreras donde les decían:
“Bueno, ¿para qué?”.
“¿Para terminar en un call center?”.
“¿Para terminar de freelancer?”.
“¿Para terminar de mesero
en alguna parte?“.
Y la respuesta de todos era:
“Lo que pasa es que lo que aprendiste
no sirve para nada”.
¡Guau! Muchísimas gracias.
Entonces fue donde me senté y dije:
no puedo regresar a hacer otra carrera,
no puedo rehacer mi vida.
No existen las dinámicas
de viaje en el tiempo,
pero puedo empezar a pensar
por qué existe lo que yo estudio.
Por qué existe la literatura.
Y es curioso, porque vengo de un país
donde hay un premio nobel de Literatura.
Hay solo seis en Latinoamérica.
Uno de esos está aquí en Guatemala,
y uno estaría pensando
que estamos nadando en escritores,
que estamos nadando en poetas
porque la literatura democratiza
el desarrollo de un país.
Tal vez no tengamos
grandes premios científicos,
tal vez tengamos una economía frágil,
pero tenemos la capacidad de hacer arte
que nos pone en los mejores
lugares del mundo.
¿Por qué?
¿Por qué entonces nos burlamos
cuando la gente dice quiero ser literato
o quiero ser escritor?
Porque lo primero que pensamos es:
Ah, sí, un escritor con sus lentes,
todo removido de la realidad,
ni siquiera con una pantalla porque
los libros electrónicos no son lo mismo.
Pero ¿cuál es la verdadera
función de un escritor?
Algo que realmente tenía que preguntarme:
Un escritor ¿para qué sirve?
¿Para qué? si no se sienta
a escribir grandes novelas.
Pues ahí fue donde llegué
a esta pequeña conclusión:
Los escritores deben aprender tap.
Y por favor, no me pidan que baile
porque eso va a ser catastrófico.
Me refiero a que entienden,
cada vez que crean un texto,
cuál es la tarea, cuál es la audiencia
y cuál es su propósito.
Porque ningún buen texto sale
sin que uno considere estos tres factores.
¿Qué estoy haciendo?
¿Para quién lo estoy haciendo?
y ¿para qué lo estoy haciendo?
Esa es la importancia
de integrar un mensaje.
Y ahí fue donde entendí
que esto es lo que debo aplicar
en la manera de entender una carrera
y en la manera de entender
una filosofía de vida, la verdad.
Porque nos enseñan que las carreras
son como los moldes de galleta.
Te van a cortar como un abogado
y toda la vida vas a ser un abogado.
Te van a cortar como un ingeniero
y toda la vida vas a ser un ingeniero.
Te van a cortar como un escritor
y probablemente vas a ser mesero.
Pero no,
y de hecho me fui dando cuenta
de este gran viaje
cuando empecé a analizar
todo lo que la gente me dijo.
“Escogiste esta carrera
porque escribir es fácil
y no te da el cerebro
para las matemáticas”.
Muchas gracias, Alejandro.
Está bien. Esa es una excusa constante
para la gente de las humanidades,
pero en las humanidades
tenemos que empezar desde cero.
“Starting from scratch”.
Estos son solo algunos
de los trabajos que he tenido,
porque dejé de pensar en la carrera
como una forma de limitación
y más como un set de destrezas,
porque entonces puedo abrirme la cabeza
y puedo hacer cualquiera de estas cosas,
y perseverar en ello.
No tengo un solo día aburrido por eso.
A ver.
Aunque te vuelvas una escritora
nadie te va a contratar
y vas a morirte de hambre.
Muchas gracias, profesor Javier.
¿Por qué tenemos esta gana
de desmotivar a la gente?
Es en serio.
Pero de nuevo pensé:
hay una audiencia para esto.
Hay una audiencia a quienes interesa
qué tienen en común
los brontosaurios y las Barbies.
Entonces yo la voy a encontrar y
voy a generar ese contenido.
Y si alguna persona dice que no tienes
posibilidad de lograrlo en las humanidades
30 días es el máximo de tiempo
que he estado desempleada,
después de haberme graduado,
después de haber confiado
en mi propia capacidad
y de cerrarme a la idea de que
las humanidades no sirven.
Y la única razón por la que
no estuve trabajando
fue porque estuve viajando
a Europa y a Sudamérica,
a compartir con otras personas
que entienden el valor de las historias,
que entienden el valor
de reconocer nuestro pasado
y de crear con la ficción,
porque es una forma
en la que nos entendemos.
Y allí es donde
he encontrado mi audiencia,
donde hay personas que creen
en la capacidad transformadora
de la literatura,
la capacidad transformadora del lenguaje.
Y bien, la que más duele,
que es la de mi familia.
Esa carrera solo te va a meter
ideas de margaritas en la cabeza.
No sirve para nada.
Muchas gracias, tío Alberto.
A lo largo de mi carrera
he escrito 210 artículos originales
en diferentes revistas iberoamericanas.
He hablado de feminismo,
he hablado de la paradoja
del lenguaje inclusivo,
he hablado de por qué no me gustan
las películas de superhéroes,
he hablado de cómo estamos construyendo
el panorama intelectual de este país.
Y lo he hecho porque
he encontrado un propósito.
He encontrado el propósito
de crear mensajes
con los que la gente se identifica
y con los que corresponde,
con los que se siente con capacidad
de expresar su opinión y sus ideas.
Y estoy orgullosa de eso,
porque ahí fue donde entendí
que lo que realmente nos enseñan
las humanidades es a escuchar,
a conectarnos con la gente,
y a saber que eso es más útil
que cualquier otra cosa.
Gracias tío Alberto y Alejandro.
Es la capacidad de desconectarnos un rato
y jugar con las ideas.
Y sí, acumulé muchísimos conocimientos.
Los conocimientos en literatura
son como todo el contenido de esta bolsa.
Bastantes cosas bastante disparejas.
Pero cada una tiene un propósito.
Con cada una podemos hacer algo.
Y cada una tiene una audiencia
que le corresponde.
Así que he tenido el sueño
que nunca imaginé.
Es distinto a lo que yo había esperado.
Yo había esperado
convertirme en escritora,
pero he tenido un viaje aún más grande
que, de hecho, también incluye
que me haya convertido en escritora.
Entonces yo sé, yo sé eso que dicen
de que lo que aprendiste
no sirve para nada.
Y estoy en paz con eso, porque está bien.
Nada sirve para todo, pero definitivamente
todo sirve para algo.
Y por eso estoy tan orgullosa
de todo lo que llevo aquí,
todo lo que me acompaña,
todo lo que me ayuda
a contar esas historias,
a formar esas ideas
y a llevar esa comunicación
tan importante que traen las humanidades.
Aun si tenemos que empezar
a pensarlas desde cero,
a pelotear con las ideas.
Lo que quiero es que
nunca se dejen convencer
de que las humanidades
son una forma de olvidar a la gente.
Es todo lo contrario.
Es un puente para que nosotros
nos comuniquemos mejor
y para que entendamos
que el mundo puede cambiar.
Pero necesitamos llevar eso,
necesitamos llevar el lado humano
y llevarlo bajo nuestro control.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)